it came true this means so much missed
my missed time I don't know why I don't
get our time I think the first time I
hardly felt it because it was awesome I
want to say thank you to you I haven't
had ducks career and I wanted more than
anything to have your respect the first
time I didn't feel it but this time I
feel it oh thank you thank you ever so
much much I'm a and sir you're doing a
great job but you're so quick with that
stick so why don't you sit cuz I may
never be here again I can't believe this
this is so super quite pretty I want to
acknowledge so many people that made
Erin Brockovich Erin Brokovich but but
first let me adjust my my dress this
movie was sinfully fun to make and turn
off that clock it's making me nervous
steven soderbergh hi
oh my god oh alright
okay thank you so much oh thank you
thank you Oh
ah when they called my name I had this
feeling I could hear half of America
going oh no go come on her why her again
you know but whatever I really want to
take all my colleagues all my friends I
look out here and you know I see my life
before my eyes
I'm gonna cry because this show has been
on his longer work I have wondered for
26 years but this would feel like thank
you so much for terminating the suspense
he is at work with everybody god blessed
that principle god blessed that
potential that we all have for making
anything possible if we think we deserve
it
I deserve this thank you
[Music]
you